well let's return to the situation in
Ukraine and also President Putin's
speech this morning with me in the
studio defense analyst Professor Michael
Clark uh what did you make of what
president petun had to say Michael yeah
well Jane it was full on uh it was the
argument that we know he's made that
Russia is actually fighting for its
survival and he's justifying the
sacrifices that the Russians are going
to have to make by saying that this is a
real struggle for our existence Russia
is now fighting against the whole of the
West and he was really saying you
mentioned the oligarchs he said well if
the oligarchs lose their property abroad
so what
um they've ought to come home and he's
really talking about bringing everybody
back into the tent bringing people
around him that he needs and so you know
there are people in the front row like
Patricia who's really important here
that's Patricia just there and he's
effectively he's the National Security
advisor but he's the ideologue patriciav
is the man who's inside Putin's head and
my goodness the things he has believed
for the last 30 years would make you
hurt girl astonishing and so here's a
and what what Pooch is really saying I
mean people like you know him and
bordnikov and Kovalchuk the banker the
billionaire Banker these are the people
that Putin gets around I mean he wants
the other oligarchs to actually come
back and and get on board with the
national struggle that's really what
he's he's saying quite an interesting
element you wouldn't have expected him
to talk about the oligarchs but he did
and he turned it into a sort of matter
of patriotism he also talked about
nuclear weapons and also the
announcement of the suspension of
Russia's participation in the start
nuclear treaty How concerned should we
be about that to you yeah it's
interesting it's called the new start
um it is the this goes back in a sense
to the late 1960s it began as a salt Pro
strategic implementation talks and then
starts strategic arms reduction talks
the first treaty was in 1972 so it goes
back you know 50 odd years and um the
new start was concluded in um by Obama
in 2010 with Medvedev there when he was
president and he came into force in
2011. in 2021 it was extended for five
more years till 2026 and Putin has
pulled out of it now in real reality
that doesn't make that much difference
because the new start treaty was only to
agree to carry on doing what they were
already doing you didn't force them to
reduce anything it just put a sort of a
a a cap on what they were anyway
planning to do so it won't make a lot of
practical difference but symbolically
it's quite important because the whole
strategic arms process this this
agreement between Russia and America on
their intercontinental ballistic
missiles targeted at each other was like
the the tip of a pyramid and underneath
that pyramid were deals on pre on the
tactical nuclear weapons intermediate
forces on conventional forces chemical
weapons biological weapons There's a
Great Pyramid of Arms Control all based
on the fact that there was this thing at
the top between the two superpowers now
in reality most of what was in that
pyramid has gone over the years and this
this it left the tip
um as it were presiding over almost
nothing but to lose it means that it
would be much more difficult now to
build that pyramid up again at some time
in the future so symbolically quite
important in Practical terms won't make
any difference to their nuclear arsenals
okay but what about what is actually
happening on the ground we're reaching
that one year anniversary what is the
situation at the moment yeah I'm more of
the same mainly in the donbass I mean
this is almost certainly is where the
Russians are going to push when their
offensive really starts I don't believe
it's really started yet I think we when
it does we'll know about it but it's all
in the donbass and three particular
places that we've mentioned many times
cremina in the north which is that the
Russians have to hold criminal and
they're pushing back with just with with
numbers of troops not with any great
skill but they're pushing back and
forcing ukrainians to give ground in
criminal back much they may take that by
the end of the week they've they've
almost they've got almost every router
back now covered if not actually
physically occupied I suspect the
ukrainians may have to withdraw from
back but they might hang on beyond the
end of the week in order to prevent the
Russians getting the benefit of an
anniversary Victory and then mainly in a
vuladar the Russians have lost an
enormous number of troops have been two
major battle tactical groups there
almost and two good ones as well the
155th and the 40th Marines and they seem
to have lost most of them which means
means that they they're combat
ineffective which means that they've
lost more than 30 percent of their
troops that's the normal uh definition
of being combat ineffective and the rmod
our defense intelligence people in
London say they've become combat
ineffective so very expensive for the
Russians but they're pushing but they're
pushing on areas that they used to
control there's nothing new in this
they're just they're just expending a
lot of Manpower and blood in order to
keep the ukrainians fighting and I think
the real offensive will start sometime
you know in the next few weeks hasn't
started yet in my view